[Music]
in new level of stocking news submitted
by go Yoko I can tell us near Christmas
cuz I thought stockings immediately like
ooh stocking presents an obsessed fan
allegedly tracked down a Japanese pop
star by studying the reflections in her
eyes holy this guy should be a freaking
detective close your eyes because I
could see where we're at you did take
selfies like this now oh my god yo black
mirror new episode they're gonna start
making contact so people can't like see
inside anti-reflective yeah yeah dude
but like does she have crystal blue eyes
are what like how does these four black
eyes yeah that's easier to see all I see
I can really see the lights in your eyes
whoa where am I you got three lights
coming you look like a Eagle Rock Oh
alright so Japanese police arrested this
man but he's a policeman so he is the 26
year old unemployed man from a clearly
we knew he didn't have it that's why you
had all that time to blow up a picture
and start going on Google Maps and and
he's also a virgin we could also he's an
insult because yeah we can and an insult
insulting insel apparently what he did
is he would take her social this 21 year
old pop singers social media photos who
enlarge her photos and analyze the
reflections in her pupils to the point
where he was able to recognize some
Tokyo scenery and a bus so she got a
really good camera because if you blow
it up like that resolution has to check
in my outfit pretty Wow pretty big cross
art like the circle lenses she's doing a
funny check of some of my textbook in
cell look dude I swear I just messed
them on like that how does he look like
a pug that's like a Japanese pug can you
tell where I am in this picture I see
the light but so then would he is that
indoor picture is that an eye
eleven that's a bit outdoor picture then
he would analyze her photos that she
took in her own apartment and then he
would so he was able to see he's [ __ ]
creepy he said oh my god is she naked
right now no though I like the
reflection from America so then she was
able to see a bus stop and he located
that using Google Street View oh hell no
and then he even approximated which
story
she lived in in the building based off
of the windows and the way she had a
[ __ ] way that the sunlight hit her
eyes
oh no good at trigonometry - yeah like
use your talents for good not evil
that's why you need to be good at maths
you could stop he's good at trigonometry
too because he's triggering and calculus
oh no you're right because he's
calculated if all of those efforts were
made toward like finding criminals all
right job they did in that movie met
theme and catch me if you can catch me
if you can at the end
hire him to work for the FBI they should
hire this guy to help catch other Stocki
that's what I do eventually but this is
the creepy part so like that wasn't the
creepy part no no that was it that was
like the normal thing real creepy part
is if you don't subscribe then you're
the real creep oh yeah you should
subscribe otherwise that's creepy you're
just stalking us without what subscribe
that's true that's like watching us
without being our friend mean wait so
then the real creepy part here is that
eventually how he when he figured out
where she lived
he would stalk he spent a long time
stalking her like in real life stalking
and then there was this one point where
he stalked her all the way home from a
concert and then he placed a towel over
her head oh dragged her into a dark
corner threw her to the ground and then
molested her he's never had sex was like
I don't know how to do this a public
busted nuts already like yes anybody so
how did they catch him so oh so then
during that whole struggle she did
suffer injuries to her face
oh the moneymaker I know he was actually
arrested 16 days after the attack took
place and that's because he confessed to
the crime and he was yeah he admitted
being obsessed with her and admitted to
studying where she lived based off the
reflection and where the cops like would
you like a job they need to give him if
they're smart like the ji a or something
ki the FBI girl's eyes are look at a
cute little tongue is she wearing those
contacts that grow yours yeah I think
she is pretty wonder if this fool was
jacking off to the picture and he's like
oh wait is that a bus stop in oh [ __ ]
can you see like that doesn't look like
[ __ ] because you don't have a braid of a
nympho I've been there before too much
I had okay so when I start working out
BuzzFeed they had they like hire maybe
I'm giving too much info do it okay well
the funny I worked anyway they hire like
a company that's combs through your
social like make sure you're protected
because we've had some like incidences
where people have shown up and
specifically me I had someone show up in
the middle of the night at an old
apartment complex I lived at in the
middle of the night at like 2:30 in the
morning in my backyard oh my god
screaming my name at the window and I
like woke up and I was like am i hearing
something and I had a boyfriend at the
time who I was like do you hear that did
he go out with his axe yeah he like went
out there
like Coco Chanel hey you better leave
and then we moved cuz I was so freaked
out what did he want
I don't know I never liked he's a soccer
dude he just wants to [ __ ] see and
touch her but is it that a perfect pop
of nudity be able to kill someone for
free yeah but no I was freaked that like
when you're in that moment you're not
like oh yeah this is my moment you're
like I feel so violated creeps well
you're not alone yeah well we both are
when they do the comb through they were
able to find so much [ __ ] about me and
my family and where I live because in
one of my old Instagram stories or
something you could see the my door in
the background and they were able to
like trace the number of the door back
to like my location and like you could
see what apartment complex I lived at
and like you don't think about this [ __ ]
first of all I'm not even famous like if
someone's really going through that kind
of trouble to get to little ol me who
will [ __ ] you for free like you don't
have to do much
think about what yeah because they know
I'm easy like Joe but they like imagine
someone like chilling - he says it but
like imagine like a superstar like that
like the lengths that people will go to
and now we have all these hackers and
crypto [ __ ] maniacs I can doesn't
that make you feel a little love okay
cuz I can take every day and turn to
blame my people need a Filipino gladder
like 2:00 in the morning someone's in my
backyard screaming my name
my mom doesn't think about me she made
me I think every girl needs to have a
gun I really do I agree with that
I really think so there's so many
there's so many weirdos out there but
what happened your anti-gun no no I'm
not anti-gun but I have mental illness
and there's no reason why I should
easily because it might go like this to
this well like I have anxiety what about
pepper spray I could do perspect
I have pepper spray on my walk but it
might spray herself but that wasn't my
point was like I shouldn't so easily be
able to get a gun when I publicly talked
about my mental illness
imagine so responsible yeah thank you I
try
that's why you need friends with guns
that you have access to you guys got
that yes [ __ ] yeah
well you're very hot oh thanks you're
welcome Barney's the first are you um
mine is like I would I would dismantle
it and then I have it like in like in
somewhere where like I can like but you
don't worry like you got depression
issue I don't have a gun but I'm just
saying I'm not against that because I've
definitely taken all over my [ __ ]
house you know like it's it's not like
or even a laser pointer so if that's
some weirdo in the backyard you just
shine on his forehead and pretend like
it's something like I got my sights on
you like even if your intentions are
good like even if you are just a fan
there's a [ __ ] level of normalcy that
people need to have where they have a
space to feel [ __ ] safe that should
be your home especially you guys are
homeowners you know you drop coin on
that [ __ ] imagine someone who violated
that [ __ ] I can't wait I'd meet you I'm
waiting for the day and you call me if I
yeah okay hey Joe I got one he's in my
backyard oh [ __ ] yeah I like it drive
over and won't [ __ ] chop him down
will show up here or like though show up
at the other place and we're just like
dude this is not like we're not open for
the public respect our privacy in our
area [ __ ] creepy yeah Gary
even though they're really nice but it's
just like what you're saying there's a
pole yeah you can [ __ ] around there's
all those soccer stories like we're like
it was her name not Natalie Natalie I
can't remember but he the when you watch
interviews with the killer he's like I
just liked her so much and so I went to
her house I found her house and I
knocked on her apartment door she's just
an apartment and I gave her the letter
that I had written and as she was like
reading opening the letter I just
couldn't help it I just shot her because
I wanted to be close to her so he wanted
that to forever connect them together
he's the one that shot her and he was
like I didn't mean to kill her but I
just wanted us to I wanted her to know
me I mean he could have just farted on
her and it would have been like a lot
easier and she would have been alive
gasps that that's true but like where do
you think the like where do you think
that switch turns in some people they're
obviously these people are mentally ill
like we're not addressing that but like
where do you think that [ __ ] switches in
their head to an unhealthy obsession
when they cross property borders or
wonder like think that's the only thing
they could think about in a day like
they're obsessed yeah when they're
thinking about that for more than
anything at like more than enough people
that are obsessed with like celebrities
like should it even or three even
thinking about what they would do in the
demagogues birthday by the way happy
birthday no me please no me no you never
zoomed into his eyes she tried that we
know psychotic moments I have a birthday
present
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]